am morgen ist der losgefahren in polen
in potsdam jetzt ist der kurz vor berlin
mehr als 300 kilometer ist der junge
pole schon gefahren sein spitzname ist
antik er ist unterwegs für amazon ohne
osteuropäische fahrer wie ihn würde das
geschäft nicht laufen
arbeit nichts als arbeit rund um die uhr
jetzt bin ich in deutschland wo ich
morgen hinfahre weiß ich heute noch
nicht
für die schufterei bekommen wir gerade
mal den mindestlohn knapp über 700 euro
im monat dazu noch ein paar spesen oder
einen umschlag auf die hand
ein deutscher fahrer in einem
vergleichbaren job verdient das drei bis
vierfache
von berlin geht es weiter erst gegen 22
uhr schicht ende irgendwo zwischen
dresden und leipzig streckt sich an teck
in seiner koje aus
am nächsten morgen geht es weiter
richtung norditalien
anand ex reise lässt sich zeigen wie das
system amazon funktioniert das
logistikzentrum in bologna
hier lädt antec waren ab die er aus
deutschland mitgebracht hat dann macht
er sich auf den weg nach frankreich sein
ziel clermont ferrand knapp 700
kilometer entfernt dort packt antec ware
aus china ein auch für kunden in
deutschland doch statt direkt zu liefern
fährt er die ganze fracht noch einmal
1400 60 kilometer weiter nach france
live in polen erst von ihr aus wird
später an kunden in westeuropa geliefert
zig tausende lkw durchqueren so jeden
tag den europäischen kontinent im
auftrag von amazon
die transportstrecken werden immer
länger weil sich das durch niedrige
löhne für amazon lohnt es ist billiger
die ware etwa aus frankreich nach polen
zu transportieren und dann wieder zurück
meistens nach deutschland zumindest
solange die löhne in polen auf einem
niedrigen niveau bleiben und so fahren
wir manchmal fast leer kaum beladen mit
nur wenigen paketen verbrauchen dabei
allerdings viel sprit
mit halb leeren lkw quer durch europa
amazon selbst sieht sich als
nachhaltiges unternehmen wie passt das
zusammen auf nachfrage erklärt der
konzern zitat die zustellung einer
typischen amazon bestellung zu einem
kunden verursacht weniger co2 als wenn
der kunde selbst zu einem geschäft
fahren würde zu kurz gedacht sagt das
umweltbundesamt
aus klimaschutzgründen ist es ganz
notwendig dass wir effizienten verkehr
haben das heißt es eine möglichst
optimale hundertprozentige auslastung
von fahrzeugen die durch die gegend
fahren sei es der zug oder sei es der
lkw aber halbleere lkws durch die gegend
zu falls auf jeden fall kontraproduktiv
wer bei amazon bestellt könnte glauben
der onlinekonzern verschicke die
angebotene ware vom hersteller direkt
zum kunden das aber ist ein trugschluss
tatsächlich gehen in deutschland
bestellte waren zunächst in polnische
großlager von dort wird die ware wieder
zurückgeschickt
insider zeigen uns bilder die dieses hin
und her belegen ein gartengrill
hergestellt in deutschland ein
schaschlik z und eine wäscheleine auch
aus deutschland
oder diese gewürze produziert in berlin
und den teutoburger wald all diese waren
von amazon werden erst nach polen
transportiert dort gelagert umverpackt
und zurück nach deutschland geliefert
der aufwand lohnt sich offenbar der
versandriese profitiert von niedrigen
lagerkosten und billigen polnischen
arbeitskräften wie am tag der ist
inzwischen auf einem autobahnrastplatz
bei nürnberg gelandet und hat die nase
voll
deutscher parkplatz die lkws stehen
dicht an dicht so ein gedränge damit der
amazon chef bezos in das weltall fliegen
karagoz
fast 8000 kilometer hat antec schon
zurückgelegt doch bis er wieder nach
hause kommt wird es noch dauern
rund eine autostunde entfernt von der
deutschen grenze in der polnischen
kleinstadt swiebodzin eröffnete amazon
vor wenigen tagen eine der weltweit
größten lagerhallen obwohl polnische
kunden für amazon bisher kaum eine rolle
spielten verabredung mit thomas filipski
der bürgermeister weiß warum amazon
hierher kommt will sie mit prof die
vorteile sind enorm und wir sind froh
dass wir so ein riesen investor gewinnen
konnten unsere stadt liegt an einem
autobahnkreuz und wir profitieren vom
standortvorteil diese investition macht
das angebot an arbeitsplätzen unserer
stadt attraktiv
zehn riesige logistikzentren betreibt
der konzern in polen 51 tausend
arbeitsplätze seien so entstanden
wir sind in poznan posen schichtwechsel
im logistikzentrum viele arbeiter kommen
von weit her
auf dem betriebsgelände protestiert die
gewerkschaft zwei drittel der
beschäftigten hätten nur befristete
verträge
viele nur für einen monat die schichten
seien bis zu zwölf stunden lang das
gehalt betrage gerade mal fünf euro die
stunde
amazon ist kein arbeitgeber der sich mit
den gewerkschaften an einen tisch setzt
wir müssen genau hingucken was sie hier
anstellen die gewerkschafterin
kritisiert dass amazon vor allem eins
wollen kosten sparen
die polnischen lagerhallen wurden nach
der großen streikwelle in deutschland
gebaut zu werden die deutschen
mitarbeiter unter druck gesetzt nicht zu
hohe forderungen zu stellen weil auch
wir hier in polen ihre pakete bedienen
können das ist eine strategische
erpressung
fest steht in der korona krise hat der
versandriese den umsatz verdoppelt auf
44 milliarden euro im vergangenen jahr
erstaunlicherweise zahlt der konzern
kaum steuern macht sogar verluste
geltend wie geht das
ronan perlen hat amazon unter die lupe
genommen auffällig die weltweiten
geschäfte des konzerns werden im kleinen
luxemburg abgewickelt luxemburg
luxemburg ist ein echtes geheimnis über
tochterunternehmen laufen die amazon
geschäfte außerhalb der usa insbesondere
aus indien oder china dort werden
gezielt verlust eingefahren diese
verluste werden wiederum zu den
luxemburger tochter unternehmen
transferiert so wird luxemburg zum
instrument um verluste in
steuergutschriften umzuwandeln da diese
gutschriften macht der konzern dann in
den vereinigten staaten gelten flugs
funding denn so werde luxemburg sagt
professor perlen zu einer art schwarzen
loch wo gewinne verschwinden und
verluste entstehen
ist eine sehr raffinierte organisation
mit einem ganzheitlichen blick auf die
welt der konzern weiß von den
verschiedenen regulierungen in
unterschiedlichen ländern gebrauch zu
machen und schließlich kaum steuern 26
nach acht stunden am steuer gibt es für
antec wieder essen aus der dose für
seine harte arbeit erwartet er mehr als
amazon ihm geben will
[Applaus]
wir die fahrer und die lagerarbeiter
erarbeiten doch den gewinn von amazon
der ist so wahnsinnig hoch weil wir tag
und nacht wochenlang außer haus sind ich
glaube wir verdienen mehr lohn und mehr
wertschätzung für unsere leistung
am nächsten morgen geht die reise weiter
noch zwei wochen wird er am steuer
sitzen damit die kunden in deutschland
und europa ihre päckchen bekommen